مليار يورو من المساعدات العسكريه
الاوروبيه لاوكرانيا مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل
وصف القرار بالتاريخي
بامكاني اوكرانيا الاستمرار بالاعتماد على
الاتحاد الاوروبي
يسعدني الاعلان عن موافقه وزراء الدفاع
والخارجيه على الاقتراح الذي يدعو الى
التزويد العاجل لاوكرانيا بالذخائر
الولايات المتحده وافقت ايضا على مساعدات
عسكريه لاوكرانيا بقيمه 350 مليون دولار
تزامن الاعلان مع اجتماع الرئيس الصيني
تشيكينج والرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين في
موسكو لقاء يقول محللون انه يروج لدور
بكين كصانع سلام محتمل في اوكرانيا
ماذا قدرتي الصين على مساعده روسيا فعليا
هذا غير واضح بالنسبه الي السبب هو انه
اذا اكتشفت الولايه المتحده مثلا تزويد
شركات صينيه روسيا بمعدات عسكريه فمن
المحتمل ان تفرض عليها عقوبه سريعه وهو
امر قد لا تقدر على تحمله الحكومه وشركات
الصينيه
اكد يفجين رئيس مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه
الروسيه ان قواته تسيطر على 70% من مدينه
بخموت كما قال ايضا ان الجيش الاوكراني
يخطط لهجوم وشيك شرق اوكر